so most people are familiar with the
idea that Vincent van Gogh had mental
illness different camps so to speak of
mental illness almost like to claim van
Gogh as their own so you know you know
groups say oh he had schizophrenia
he had bipolar disorder I would argue
that van Gogh who clearly had documented
certain symptoms which ranged from being
highly irritable and at the same time
what's called very sticky stickiness is
the psychiatric term which means you you
bond to people and sort of cling on and
and keep engaging with them in a very
very intense way but when someone is
both sticky and irritable it causes what
happened to van Gogh which is he would
make these intense relationships with
his brother for example with Goga so
certain artists and with with women that
weren't necessarily be suitable women
for him and at the same time he would
then have these tremendous arguments and
fights with them so they were chaotic
relationships and they were I'm very
close no I can't have anything to do
with you that really wreaked terrible
havoc in his life in addition to those
two symptoms he also suffered with
extreme depression at various times real
mood lability so sometimes he was
intensely depressed other times he was
seemingly more up and those go together
along with something very interesting
which is his paintings so in his
paintings we see intense color and a
difference in terms of paintings that
preceded it which which weren't more
realistic his paintings have this more
abstract quality almost in some ways
like a nightmarish quality to them and
that makes you think about again what
was going on his mind that he produced
something like that if you look at all
of those qualities you think about
temporal lobe epilepsy
temporal lobe epilepsy is not like other
forms of epilepsy where you have a
seizure happen that you can see because
it's happening in the temporal lobe
which is an emotional center of the
brain so that symptoms of temporal lobe
epilepsy are this mood lability
stickiness irritability or a civility
and so being a frustrating person and
visual hallucinations so seeing visually
in your own mind intensities of color
heightened sensory visual stimuli like
this essentially starry night or you
know something that looked very dramatic
impressionistic or even visual
hallucinations that alter with someone
else looks like so it can so people have
temporal lobe epilepsy might look at
your face and see distortions and of
course when we look at some of Van
Gogh's paintings you often do see such
distortions the interesting thing is
that ultimately when he was hospitalized
in REME the doctor actually thought he
did have epilepsy and treated him for
epilepsy so there was even knowledge at
that time that there could be this kind
of illness causing his problems and in
fact this all fits with the time periods
during which he becomes most ill which
is when he would drink absinthe absinthe
was an alcohol that was very in during
various periods of Van Gogh's life and
it has a very high pure alcohol content
which lowers the seizure threshold in
the brain so people who have epilepsy
have to stay away from alcohol and are
usually medicated with something that
lowers the seizure threshold of the
brain if one would drink absinthe and
have a temporal lobe epilepsy you would
expect a real rise in the amount of
activity going on and and
and more illness to the point even of
being psychotic which did ultimately
happen to their go in the incident where
he you know had this big blowup with
another artist and and you know hurt his
ear you know cut off a piece of his ear
and so on so these things these pieces
all essentially fit together to create
this picture that that is a likely
diagnosis again one can never 100%
retrospectively diagnose someone but
these would all fit with temporal lobe
epilepsy and they would also explain
what might have informed some of Van
Gogh's work and no doubt he you know is
a brilliant was a brilliant artist but
some of his work may have been informed
actually by his illness and and that is
what we see today